i always want to pull over and just pick
up all this [ __ ] litter
kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ] does that kind
of person that rides a bicycle out on
the street that's who does it
i already have like a huge temper and
i'm trying to learn how to control it
and driving on these
streets out here like makes me lose my
[ __ ] again you know people always say
with your anger
is when you have expectations to other
people but what can i say i'm a dreamer
all right we're in hollywood right now
nobody knows how to [ __ ] drive out
here
motorcycle i always look out for these
guys but i do not care about people on
bicycles in la
it's not a tragedy if you die out here
they're such [ __ ]
[ __ ] they ride right out in the street
right
and they're always telling you share the
road and they won't get the [ __ ] over
get over you see me behind you i'm in a
[ __ ] car get the [ __ ] over
they always giving you the finger and
[ __ ] acting like they're these [ __ ]
angels
right they never stop at stop signs they
don't obey the rules of the road that's
what the [ __ ] they're supposed to do
and then they [ __ ] ride right out in
the middle of the road like like you
pulled up into their own bike race
with their stupid [ __ ] tight outfits
on like they're doing some sort of time
trial that anybody gives a [ __ ] about
i think when they frost the bicycle too
like it was a [ __ ] tragedy
it was inevitable you're on a motorcycle
without a [ __ ] engine
driving out in traffic where people are
texting gee what could go wrong
so just [ __ ] sneak over i'll go over
the double line a little bit i'll get
around you you won't get hit
nobody has to frost the [ __ ] bicycle
okay look at this see this this person
coming up on the scooter look what i do
look what i do
i get over go ahead go live your dream
go find love
[Laughter]
look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] get out of the
[ __ ] road
look at this she's pretty though right
you can't get mad
but you know what funny if i hit her
it's my fault you're on a [ __ ]
scooter crossing four lanes of [ __ ]
traffic
who raised her right aren't you supposed
to have a helmet on
so if you're on a bicycle just [ __ ]
edge over i don't want to hit you
all right but the longer you stay out
there it starts to feel like a good
option
i always lose my [ __ ] when i'm driving
most of it's because i have a temper
the other part is i don't leave enough
time and then like the other like
i don't know 40 percent of it is that
people suck at driving
i mean i don't think i'm the greatest
driver but you know what i am
considerate
people walking in the crosswalk hustle
oh they got there you always
you know a woman goes by and she's got
the heels on there you know what he's
supposed to do can't run into tippy toes
like walter payton did
although walter payton ran on his
tiptoes his whole [ __ ] career he
never got a knee injury
look at that guy tell me that guy didn't
know where whitey bulger was all these
years
watch this guy watch this [ __ ]
[ __ ] the one pedestrian out here
right when i want to make a left look at
this [ __ ] guy on his phone
walking as slow as you can slow as you
can
i always jog in the crosswalk all right
i get across
i do the wave
now what's that guy he's got the rainbow
boots oh yeah okay i thought those were
pants
he actually has a tan his pants his legs
are the same color
is he supposed to be the reno
who's having 911 fun than this guy you
know i think if every cop dressed that
way and like there would be no more
[ __ ]
violence you know what i mean guy just
come up sorry
okay you're going a little fast i got
how you doing sweetie pie
[Laughter]
you see him just giving the thumbs up to
the fire department i [ __ ] love that
guy
[Applause]
hands at ten and two checking my mirrors
making sure
everybody's where they need to be oh
it's a one-way fuck-o
i've done that oh it's somebody's mom
god bless you god bless you mom you know
what she [ __ ] up
she realized it she backed up and then
she waved
this is classic look at this guy he's
gonna have his ass in my [ __ ] lane
then you beep at him and they don't
understand why
probably because they can't hear the
thoughts in my head now watch this now i
go to take a left i make sure i get my
whole [ __ ] vehicle in the left lane
so some other [ __ ] can pull up his
okay here i am going to make a left
right i'm getting the [ __ ] out there
i want that guy in the blue car to make
it watch i'm going to do this
i'm going to do this right
now at least the other guy he's going to
make it i actually do this actually look
in my rear view mirror to see if he may
as i don't look where i'm going
there you go just open the [ __ ] door
don't look you [ __ ] [ __ ] idiot if i
took his door off that's my fault
[Music]
everybody should just be banging a
[ __ ] right on red up here
keep it moving something somebody do
[ __ ] something you know what it is
there's no teamwork out here everybody's
like just
out here for themselves you're on a
bicycle i get it that's one less car on
the road good for you
i'm behind you get the [ __ ] over you're
the first guy to make a left
get out there so the other two people
behind you can [ __ ] make the light
will you get out of my [ __ ] lane you
[ __ ] idiot
texting of course texting
texting texting why do i yell he can't
hear me
because you guys watch me lose my
[ __ ] [ __ ] here hopefully i'm gonna
say something
and it's gonna make some of you oh i do
that maybe i won't do that anymore and
then i won't be such a psycho
is that what i'm trying i don't know
what i'm trying to do here so where i
want to be
is about a block and a half away and
this is going to take me every bit of
like 17 minutes to get there
i mean we've literally been sitting here
for like 20 [ __ ] lights
somebody should be overturned and on
fire up here
for the level of [ __ ] traffic that's
going on where are
all of these [ __ ] people going like
one of the
advantages of being a stand-up comedian
is that everybody's at work during the
day and i should be able to just cruise
around
throwing [ __ ] rose petals out the
goddamn window and how wide open it is
it just never happens
i work from home i
started a business it's [ __ ] insane
goddamn baby could crawl on the [ __ ]
sidewalk
and get there faster this really is
stupid
all right i gotta make a left here who's
gonna let me in who's gonna how about
you you're gonna let me in you're gonna
let me in
course not why would you let me in you
could go another two feet let me in
thank you thank you maybe i still do the
wave even though you didn't [ __ ] let
me in
this is why i never want to leave my
house i love my wife but she always does
that [ __ ] like we should do something
today today be a good day to do
something you want to do something today
and it's just like yeah
i would love to if it wouldn't take four
[ __ ] hours to get to the something
and by the time i get there i want to
kill myself
i can't imagine living in like nebraska
and they just hey you want to do
something today
and you just get in your car and you're
driving you go [ __ ] do it
half the homeless people out here just
got sick of driving that's what it is
just pulled over and just said the hell
with it
i i can't [ __ ] do this i just can't
do it i don't give a [ __ ] i'm gonna find
some other [ __ ] way how do i back
this up how do i back it up
oh there it is people hate me
right now people hate me
[Music]
i like this person i like how this
person is driving before it even
turns green they're already pulling up
they're ready to go i judge their
parents on how they react to the light
you should be like big daddy down
garlands as soon as that tree turns
green man you stand on it son
go you [ __ ] go go not yet
oh that would have been disastrous don't
listen to me
but he has on a sweater and a nice hat
now that's a love story you can watch a
woman underneath an overpass and she's
still captivated by you every word
that's a love story that actually warms
my heart chances are
go go go there you go good move good
move
good move
all right now we're on the uh we're on
the highway every place else in the
world
the further left you are on the highway
the faster you're supposed to be going
you're not supposed to pass on the right
but every [ __ ] out here that's exactly
what they do
so when you're trying to get off you got
to go like [ __ ] 90 miles an hour come
on let me
let me in this person you're going to
let me in you douche you see my [ __ ]
turn signal
thank you even when they're a douche you
still wave stops them from taking the
gun out of their [ __ ] glove box
now look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] giant
green bus
all the way over on the left what are
you doing
except slowing people down this is like
the manson family bus
what are you doing what are you doing
oh he's trying to get over see that was
my fault
and i passed on the right i'm so full of
[ __ ]
ah that was bad and the guy was black so
maybe he thought it was yelling
something racist i mean the whole fan
don't and i'm wearing like the [ __ ]
like i feel like this is a classic
racist white guy sweater you know what i
mean you just look like you're ready to
take a family photo
and then you say like the most horrible
thing ever hi
welcome to the neighborhood i'll tell
you they got to build that wall
i got to build that [ __ ] wall man
what do i do i get in front of the van
you get in front of the van man you get
in front of the van and watch this i cut
in front of this [ __ ] guy
but i do the wave thank you thank you
look at this lady [ __ ] texting
looking right down i thought she she's
either
trimming her [ __ ] pubes or she's
texting
and i'm watching her text so i'm part of
the problem and i would say something
but in today's
climate i would probably get busted for
some sort of harassment
now here's the thing too when you're in
this traffic follow
you know safely behind but don't be that
douche that leaves like 20 [ __ ]
car lengths like you're trying to prove
some philosophical point you know like
hey man like
if like 10 people get in front of me i
mean i'll only get there nine seconds
later so like where's the hassle
that's when you wish you had like some
sort of [ __ ] thing that you didn't
care about on the front of your car
whatever you call those things those
things they had in tj hooker and you
just slam into him
repeatedly this is where you just start
getting claustrophobic you just want to
stop [ __ ] slamming into people
get off of me all right can i get over
can i get over please
thank you sunday was when the traffic is
really [ __ ] bad i fantasize about
living on top of that hill right over
there where there's no other houses
and just having a zip line right to
where i go to work
right into my [ __ ] office of course
i'd have to walk home right
but getting to work would be awesome i
hate seeing all this litter on the side
of the road
they ought to give you the opt out like
what do you want to do you want to do
jury duty
or do you want to pick up litter you
just have to do one on one little
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] look how depressing that is
we're just throwing all this [ __ ] out
there
you clean it up christ you clean it up
what kind of a [ __ ] animal just
drives down the road and throws this
[ __ ] out
it's [ __ ] unbelievable how are you
raised you know what's funny
you're not really throwing your trash
out properly are you you're just putting
it and they're taking it away to throw
it
again outside someplace else that we
don't have to see it right
you throw it out where all the porpoises
are out there in the ocean
that's true i was actually looking up
the history of garbage the other day
it was this whole long article and i was
just like this is too long for me to
read this
i was gonna change my behavior but now
i'm not look at this some rich guy's
building a [ __ ] skateboard ramp for
his kid
he's gonna have that giant truck pull
right up and have illegal immigrants
under the age of eight lifting all of
that up there and you think that'll be
reported of course not but you know what
i mean
matt lauer comes sashaying in with his
junk out of his pants and all of a
sudden that's the story
i mean where's the justice having said
that sexual predators need to be
eradicated out of our society
i just want to roll my window down and
talk to these people and speak where are
you going
where the [ __ ] am i going i'm not going
anywhere i'm driving around out here to
talk about how bad the traffic is so i
guess i'm worse
[ __ ] rips
is ribs usa still out here that little
rib joint
mcdonald's with spanish tile on top of
it if you're gonna build a mcdonald's
you have to make it look like the
neighborhood
you will adjust to us before you sell
your poison thank you very much
it's now right there get the [ __ ] out
there that guy did nothing wrong
it already turned yellow but you know
whenever you go to make a left you want
to try to make sure three people there's
a person texting while they walk across
the street should we legally be able to
drive by
open your door and hit him i think
actually got no fight with this guy
he's walking across the crosswalk and
the arrow was green and this person
didn't go and i was like what the [ __ ]
and then they finally went and i tried
to make the light and by then people
were in the
crosswalk thing and he was just this
mexican dude he's like yo bro
it says walk and i was like the light
screen i could tell he was gonna do
something in my truck
and uh at the last second before he
walked away
he slapped my mirror or something like
that and then i said all this steven
seagal [ __ ] at him
as he walked away as if i could beat the
[ __ ] out of him with my [ __ ] up ribs
messed up shoulder and my lack of quick
twitch muscle fiber
but you know when you're in your car you
feel safe
in and out burger there's always a line
i think when you get a pedestrian mad
enough to slap the mirror
off the side of your car i mean that's
usually a good indication that uh you
know you're probably not interacting
with your fellow man the way you should
be
firehouse subs you're like that's a
great name huh just sounds like you're
gonna get diarrhea
there's a fire in my ass thanks for the
subs
would you like some peppers on that no i
wouldn't firehouse subs
that beautiful woman coming out of
[ __ ] domino's pizza
gorgeous look at that dog right there
i don't care in the world i think he
gives a [ __ ] about global warming
does it somebody could write a great
coffee table book about that about how
to get into the mentality of a dog with
its head out the window
and there'd be enough [ __ ] morons out
there that would buy it
and literally start driving down the
street like ace ventura hey like this
lady there go ahead go ahead yes
god bless you and your hat god bless you
and your hat and your hand and your dog
that's not safe that's not safe
why have children have dogs right that's
what bob barker used to say
spay and neuter yourselves and have more
cats and dogs
now the hipster guy with his tight jeans
he's never having kids that's why these
millennials never
you know they're not having kids the way
other generations have it's not they're
not trying
i mean everybody's out there banging
it's just when your jings are that tight
it's just you know it's killing an
entire generation
dude there's like a ramen place every
five feet i don't understand what people
are so excited about [ __ ] ramen
noodles for
even if they taste good you want to sit
around another 20 people making that
noise
[ __ ] hannibal lecter fava beans noise
the entire time
you got to get ramen noodles to go
that's a to-go item or they should make
you sit outside on a windy day when you
eat it so no one has to listen to you
slurping this [ __ ] up
no matter how broke i was i never drove
a car like that at some point you just
got to take out the credit card and get
the [ __ ] back bumper fixed
you don't accept it the second you
reattach the license plate you just
accepted you
that's like you put on some pounds and
rather than eating a salad you buy the
next size of
pants right you just accepted the fact
that you're slowly gonna become a fat
[ __ ]
you know these [ __ ] people with their
bumpers
and their [ __ ] bellies i've just had it
there it is ribs usa i should probably
shut the car off
global warming you know
i'm in indianapolis indiana home of uh
the wine and ass indianapolis colts oh
they cheated they took a [ __ ] hair out
of the ball
that's why we lost by 35 unbelievable
this is what i love about jim irsay that
bitching made a stick
and he works right there hey jimmy
he's probably still up from last night
if you know what i mean
anyways we're gonna be going over to uh
the indianapolis
motor speedway the indy 500. oh that's
what indianapolis is home of
the motor speedway this old woman
smoking cigarettes
is that a guy no it's a woman i love the
midwest they haven't seen a surge in
general support in their entire life
they don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] smoking
cigarettes with some
raw red meat in their front shirt pocket
look at this coffee smiling
i like indianapolis this guy's got a
shovel
always filling up the potholes man they
got money out here huh you never see
that in l.a
oh i see what they're doing the indy
500's here so
that's they're filling up the potholes
they're making it look good
all right so right now we're on our way
to the indianapolis motor speedway
home of the indianapolis 500 which is
going to be going down this
uh memorial day weekend what's amazing
about this speedway is when you first
see you cannot [ __ ] believe how big
it is
because you forget that it has to be big
enough that people could be driving 200
miles an hour
so we're going to meet one of the
drivers who's going to take me out on
the track
i know who you think who's going to
drive you around bill rick nears
gordon john [ __ ] a.j foyt
no none of those old coots half of them
are probably dead
the one and only danica patrick a lovely
lady do you realize how legendary this
place is i almost got the chills when i
pulled in here
holy [ __ ] this is awesome
all right bill burr here i am
indianapolis motor speedway with the
legendary danica patrick
gonna take a lap and i'm going to tell
you right now i hate being in the
passenger seat i'm definitely going to
get freaked out
do you get bored like after you do a
race you don't drive yourself home do
you like you know so you're just sitting
and stuff and go traffic in like a
subaru
have you had like one of those ricky
bobby sort of uh
rivalries with any driver that even if
you came in seventh as long as they came
an atheist site
actually in racing that uh tends to be a
problem within
teammates usually you have
the most similar equipment as they do so
it's the
bigger test of talent i saw that with
lewis hamilton and nico rosberg there
you go and formula one it's
very very hilarious this is it right
here this is so iconic
i can't believe i'm here right now you
know what eric notice about you
steely like calm cruising around here
thank you
and you're just like well you know you
just stay here you stay along the wall
i mean you're entering the corner at 230
235 miles an hour without lifting
235 miles it does sound pretty cool
actually doesn't it
how will you just ride right on
somebody's ass like that just knowing
the whole time that all someone has to
do
is just just clip you in the back and
you're going to go flying into the wall
you just don't think about it right yeah
you're so focused like i'm going to get
around this
thoughts become things let's not uh
let's not think about those things let's
take this time
and you just come up with that that's
awesome i'm pretty sure i didn't come up
with it but i'm pretty sure it's
i'm pretty sure it's a saying but i want
to use that with my wife it's true
thoughts become things
i don't want to go too fast but i was
thinking i'd speed it up a little bit
yeah
let me get the experience i went here in
95 and 96. i used to watch this
every year when i was growing up you
know rick mears and
yeah mario andretti
see this is cool then you come up along
the wall now this must feel like you're
in like
still in first gear well i mean the car
rolls around and moves a lot
you know compared to the other cars
oh yeah i thought i was going to be
nervous but you're like so like
calm how long you been doing this uh
this is my 27th um
season of racing 27th and you're
retiring right
i am i think that's awesome thank you
i'm so glad finally somebody's like
excited about me retiring like it's
beautiful your left is still in your
prime
like i don't know how it works with race
car drivers you know with athletes like
you know when you got to run around and
stuff your body breaks down and then it
kind of starts to get sad
you're not as fast how do you age out of
racing
i think that you just don't care enough
anymore and there's so much
risk on the line that you start thinking
about that part of it
have you ever been driving like 200
miles an hour right on somebody's
ass someone right behind you and you
just start thinking about like going to
the mall or something and you
is that when you start thinking like i
gotta get out of racing
no like i wonder if they're gonna make
another anchor man then you're like wait
a minute i'm an indy 500 right now
i hope they make another anchorman and
bob anchorman like an all-time favorite
of mine
but i kind of pictured you as like the
veronica corning stone
like all these people well she was like
yeah
qualified when is your last race gonna
be um
may 27th sunday maybe oh this is it
yeah it's in a few days oh my god this
so this is like a legendary uh
trip around we're on the track with you
how many miles around is this
two and a half two and a half miles
around so it's uh 200 laps 500 miles
do you have any idea what lap you're on
after a while
actually you get very confused sometimes
there are parts in the race and you're
like we're only on lap 35
or you're like holy crap how is it 40 to
go
you know like there are certain points
in the race that go a lot faster than
other points
i can relate to that as a comedian this
night you go on stage and you're
thinking i must have done 50 minutes
and you've only been up there for like
11 and but you somehow
burned through most of your act oh
that's a good one
completely feeling my face getting
pulled over here this is awesome
i literally am going twice as fast in an
indy car than this
double the speed oh that's how cool is
that now how do you how do you
maintain your calm when you're leading
at a place like this
without thinking like don't blow this
well
i say to myself i mean you
you just get very singularly focused
you're thinking to yourself like
you know how does the car feel how do i
stay ahead of the balance how do i make
sure that i don't
you know the front stays hooked up and i
don't let it get you know too much
understeer too fast and then not be able
to turn
and then you know what are the other
cars doing
and you know looking in your mirrors you
listen to your spotter
you're hearing if anybody's off strategy
you know you're kind of
i understand it's got a lot going on
some of that i understood
well i think that's going to have to be
our trigger fire
that was awesome how fast were we going
when you really were going because when
we were doing 8 21 30 yeah
i think this is a good player i can't
believe i just got to do that that was
so cool
thank you so much yeah of course all
right there you go
legendary uh indianapolis motor speedway
i want to thank danica patrick
for not uh hitting the wall or anything
like that it's my job steely calm i
thought i was gonna be nervous i wasn't
it was awesome
none of those tourists over there care
about me
[Music]
this is bill burr and i'm doing another
one of these driving videos these how to
how to drive a little more courteous
people out there there's so much
screaming and yelling on facebook
wouldn't it be nice if it stopped when
you got on the road
i'm in uh i'm in indianapolis indiana
home of
uh home of this downtown area i mean
who's kidding who the [ __ ] pacers
never won anything did they
they don't have a hockey team they don't
have a baseball team
oh would you shut up you [ __ ] no
sorry me too i ended that was very
strong
it's very strong you'd interrupt me so
rudely anyways
there's a downtown area where you arrive
at your destination on the right you
just can't have this [ __ ] thing
for some reason in downtown indianapolis
we have enough lanes for like a highway
this [ __ ] thing
shut up the [ __ ] ate that navigation
thing i can't stand it i remember back
in the day you just you just you had a
map
was it i know i sound like an old guy
but you could at least continue to
listen to your song
pour some sugar on me back then in the
the late 80s
it always comes on during the best part
you know you're totally in your fantasy
you're playing the guitar solo in front
of everybody who did you wrong
and they were like wow we were really
wrong about him and then all of a sudden
it's like
make a left alright here we go this is
counting down
i had plenty of time to get through the
caution light so then you know
i make that guy be first and i lose the
people behind us filming us
it's tremendous
anyway this guy's staring hard at me
staring hard at me i hope he doesn't
have any [ __ ] issues with cameras
[ __ ] are you looking at good lord do
they not have cameras out here
they never filmed the [ __ ] episode of
the real housewives of indianapolis
you know with them putting their
horseshoes on the bottom of those
[ __ ]
high heels oh that's that was me that
was mean so anyways if you notice i just
made a nice left turn there
i used my turn signal and then i sped up
a little bit so this guy behind me
wouldn't get mad
there's nothing wrong with somebody
coming into your lane as long as you
keep [ __ ] going
it's that [ __ ] where you coming and then
you step on the brakes like all right no
not sure how to do this very patriotic
license plates out here
a lot of people out here indiana very
proud
to be americans if you know what i mean
the clan is strong in this state
it's all i'm saying
once again there's just no traffic
there's literally no traffic
the second you put these cameras on the
car everybody just takes off you saw
what that how that guy was staring
he saw you staring
by the way don't do that when you're
going up to an intersection
well up here on the right is the uh the
alexander it's a big thing to do with uh
buildings and hotels now
you do the ohio state thing you put the
in front of it and then everybody's like
oh
[ __ ] this must be special it really
isn't
you know what you can never use when
you're in a hotel you can never use
a uh a face cloth
ever unless you're wiping something up
because like i'm convinced like
like 40 loads a month are shot into
those goddamn things
you know i guess unless you're jerking
off into one other than that i'd keep it
away from your face
yeah i'm just going to rename these
videos bill cruises around while
everybody stays in their own lane
you know what i'm realizing i think i've
i've just been a psycho
and all this stuff i think that's
happening every five seconds actually
maybe happens once a drive
you gotta love a good bus station you
know there's sure there's a lot of
degenerates down there but there's
always like a
jewel or something living in a locker
getting ready to sing another hit song
who will say
the old fail whatever she used to say
running another red light
cruising on through there you go and the
guy behind me made it
our own film crew you want to speed up
you want to make the flight you want to
get through it
i'm gonna ignore those people in the
wheelchairs
oh just gliding through the city as if
there's no purpose for these videos
look at me i got my hand on the wheel
like this i'm leaning cutting over nine
lanes
nobody beeping at me i'll tell you one
thing these people in indianapolis
they [ __ ] work they get to work and
that's it
or they're still sleeping is this a
speed trap
what's the speed like 15 miles an hour
oh it's so the guy can
if he's painting the line he's got to do
it himself
he's got to push it ah that's adorable
event in progress
road closure shut the [ __ ] up this is
alert she just said the road's closed
that's not close
look at this [ __ ] working out up
there
he's going he's doing burpees what is it
with crossfit people that they can't
just work out
everybody's got to know you're working
out it's like i work out
i do it inside goes up to the top of the
statue like he's in rocky
[Music]
all right so that was downtown
indianapolis now you're supposed to get
up to speed here
before you get over the on-ramp is
designed to get your speed up you know
what i see people do on the highway
never see that person that pulled over
to stop and then they're sitting in the
breakdown lane and they want to rejoin
people driving 70 miles an hour and they
put their blinker on and they just
pull out you got to get your speed up
get up to about 50
55 and then then you come over it's all
common sense right
it all makes sense to me look at that
giant stupid lucas oil field stadium you
know these poor people here they're
still paying for uh
they're still paying for the hoosier
dump that cheating bastard
i'll tell you one thing i would never be
out here in indiana i'd never be a
an uber driver i mean there's literally
nobody here
this level of people so this is like
what this is what you dream about
there's cruising all right
this is getting a little weird it's just
people walking down the middle of the
street here
we in the back woods now faster and
turkey [ __ ] through a ten horn
that [ __ ] rock if i thought a
snake was under it
none of these make sense you know living
in la this this blows my mind
i forgot how just how green it can be
you know
you ever flown across the country from
east coast to the west coast it's like
watching somebody's life
you know it starts off all beautiful
lush you know all the water that's like
when you
still get full head of hair it's all
shiny in the middle of the country it
kind of levels out that's when you get
married you having kids
just gonna do this i'm staying with you
the rocky mountains those are when you
get kidney stones
then you get out to the southwest and
it's just all [ __ ]
get that first pain in your side right
look at this perfect right near a
graveyard
it all just goes [ __ ] right back down
again right into the ocean
i i swear too much i got to clean up my
act
golly jakers i'm driving like a jerk
face
all right this thing's gonna be talking
the whole time
whatever we can leave her on i'll
improvise with her hey what's going on
it's bill burr and i'm talking over the
robot lady on the map here and it's time
for another one of my instructional
driving videos
here on the all things comedy network
for those of you unfamiliar with these
videos
i have a tendency to lose my [ __ ] and
evidently according to people who think
that they're therapists they tell me
it's because i have expectations of
people
what are you doing what are you doing
are you coming over
are you coming over go you [ __ ] [ __ ]
nice move though that wasn't bad
everybody's doing everything correctly
out here
this is like perfect thursday and i make
another light
this is [ __ ] i feel like i'm in the
presidential caravan right now
a couple of secret service guys you know
hanging on to the side with their
[ __ ]
running board in the handle this is like
perfect thursday
and i make another light i don't know
what this street is but this is my
this is my most favorite [ __ ] street
in los angeles i've literally not hit a
[ __ ] red light
there's nothing funnier than a red light
okay now you step on the gas
you blow through the light you make sure
the guy behind you makes it he didn't
because he's lollygagging but i'm
thinking about him see
i'm having empathy for other people
here's another green light
please turn left in 500 feet now how can
i turn
left here this says no left turn look at
this thing it wants to make an illegal
turn here
well i guess i can make a u-turn can i
do it right here we're gonna find out
all right now what i just did there
you're not supposed to do that unless
you look both ways and you don't see a
cop
jesus [ __ ] christ this is what i feel
like i'm on adam 12.
it's like the population of l.a in the
1960s
i feel like like a plague hit la and
like everybody died right as we were
putting these [ __ ] cameras up look at
this
everybody just behaving themselves
staying in the correct lanes
i don't think we need to make any more
of these videos i think everybody's
driving great now
i didn't realize there was desolate
areas of greater los angeles i feel like
we found it
all right i just made it right in the
left lane right onto saturday street
it's that okay
wait am i the problem i think i'm the
problem
oh my goodness look at dude there's
literally nobody on the [ __ ] road
this is [ __ ] hilarious i've never had
this driving experience ever in l.a
this is like a feel-good movie today was
everything worked out
did i just [ __ ] that up i think i did
i'm in the wrong goddamn lane
all right now i'm going to show you
something you're not supposed to do
this is called the glide you sort of
sashay over
this is going to be a [ __ ] boston
move right here
and here we go and you can't get mad
when somebody beeps at you when you do
this
what you do is you just kind of you just
kind of you just kind of do this like
hey
i'm just sort of mirroring your
movements
and he didn't beep at me all right you
see that
kept a little distance there's only
arrows there pointing which way i was
supposed to be going
i'm the worst well i don't think we
learned a lot today
other than what not to do the way i was
driving people i don't pretend to know
things
and shouldn't you be at work right now
instead of sitting in your cubicle
secretly watching these things
i don't even know what i did i just
literally went for like one of the most
pleasurable [ __ ] drives
i've ever gone in la that was like a
country road
and i'm gonna take credit for that i
think everybody's listening i think i'm
changing lives
with these videos all right well thank
you for watching
i hope it was educational i hope it was
entertaining have a nice day and god
bless the united states of america
all right i'm showing this is the part
of la you're never going to see this is
up north in the valley oh another
apartment building yeah because we need
more people
i'd love to be an old guy living in the
valley someday you know just walking
around my striped shirt
just talked to the other old bitties
down there at the coffee shop
drinking again and thinking of when
when you loved me
i'm having a few i want a day drink
roscoe boulevard okay this [ __ ]
lunatic
looking down at a goddamn phone
i wish it was a [ __ ] sign or some
[ __ ] you know i don't mind her cause
she's kind of aggressive
so they come up and they go to like bump
into you
this guy looking at us like he's gonna
get discovered i swear to god there's
something about
the valley that just makes you like 2 3
in the afternoon you just want to go
into
into a bar you know
meet some guy that did a guest star on
like emergency
i used to be on a show watch out i was
on chips get the [ __ ] out of here
what was eric estrada like oh he's a
great guy
so you know that guy right over there he
should have made that [ __ ] left and
he didn't make it
then he turns his direction on that's a
big la thing you wait until the light
turns green and then you put your
directional on you leave that person
right up against your bumper
this guy sells sandwiches and doughnuts
just got a picture you got to pick a
[ __ ]
it's probably delicious right look at
that piece of [ __ ]
just these run down strip malls and
it'll be like the greatest
[ __ ] donut you ever had that was a
nice u-turn that guy just made there i
like that one you know
he did it he got out of the way
everything was fine
this guy's having a [ __ ] cookout
right here dude that is like next level
homeless
dude the valley is the place to be
homeless so he's cleaning up after
himself
oh [ __ ] the adult con why are we driving
in the opposite
direction of that dude everybody watches
porn but can you imagine he's showing up
to that [ __ ] thing
i'm a really big fan of your work
just creeping them out oh my god could
you have enough security at that thing
oh [ __ ] see what i did there i just
stopped so this guy could cut the corner
to look out for the trucks that's
another thing you got to watch out for
is all these [ __ ] who cut in front
of trucks when they you know they got
all that weight
behind them they can't stop
what i love about the valley look at all
those signs out there all these old
school signs
back when we thought we were going to
like colonize the moon and [ __ ] you know
us fitness mega center
old school movie theater dude this is
the [ __ ] i bet there's some really good
places to eat out here and
[ __ ] in and out burger without a line
wow oh there's the light
that ain't bad there's so no traffic i'm
doing a bunch of [ __ ] you shouldn't be
doing i'm looking at the drive through
it [ __ ] in and out
how does burger king survive this close
to an in and out there's nobody in there
there's a whole bunch of nothing right
[ __ ] there that when you get a kid
people buy it buy you a big [ __ ] pink
teddy bear
jesus you see that lady in the terry
bradshaw sure with the fishnets
maybe she's some of the talent there at
the spearmint rhino
jesus have you ever seen so many sun
damaged people in your life you get
[ __ ] get out here man
this is the desert
if i lived here i would sweep up all of
that [ __ ] trash just
for my own [ __ ] well-being look at
that was that the original walmart
where the [ __ ] are we dude the valley is
the [ __ ]
it's the place to be i wonder what a
house costs out here
you